for a show to be good is it always
necessary to have a complex plot and a
deep cast of characters can masterful
visual and sound production elevate an
average story to a great one i believe
kimitsu no yaiba proves that it can
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like there are only two types of
opinions about kimit's noiba either you
love it as one of the best anime of the
decades or you hate it as an overly
hyped story with little to back it up so
now after the movie that absolutely
broke the box offices in japan and with
the widely anticipated release of the
second season i finally want to share my
honest thoughts on this highly
controversial anime hi my name is manu
i'm getting really tired of all the
demon slayer merch in japan seriously
every convenience store has some
chocolate or beverage with something
from the series on it but nonetheless i
want to convince you today that it's
absolutely worth watching kimitsu nuyba
with a heavy emphasis on the watching
part before we can get into the part of
the show that i absolutely love and that
ultimately made me recommend this show i
want to address some criticism that i
have this anime undoubtedly set new
standards in some aspects but is quite
underwhelming in others which i feel is
what led to the polarized opinions
around it the biggest criticism you hear
around the story is its writing but
that's such a general criticism that it
physically pains me whenever someone
says it writing as a whole consists of
so many parts the world the premise the
plot the characters the dialogue and
much much more that being said i
promised that i would start with some
honest negative feedback one of my
favorite things in storytelling are
great characters people who are
relatable or detestable or inspiring any
of these but generally feel like real
people who go on some sort of journey
throughout the story and i honestly
gotta say that demon slayer does not
have great character writing tanjiro is
an interesting take on the shonen hero
trope one of the better characters in
the story overall and definitely not as
terrible as many people claim but i also
have to admit that he doesn't impact me
on a personal level as a luffy or an
itadore would and in a way is almost a
little bit too good does that make sense
were there very few morally questionable
actions from his side that make him feel
more like a real person
now almost all of the characters have a
distinctive quirk that makes them unique
but at the same time lack proper
characterization zeitsu is probably the
most annoying aspect of the entire show
for me because even with his backstory
we don't really get a good impression as
for why he behaves this way and honestly
the joke with his character as an
over-the-top coward drags on way too
long i think
and at least up to now there is
literally no redeeming aspect to his
character similarly inosca's quirk is
also a bit too much however compared to
zeitsu he has a lot more character
development in this regard early on and
another aspect that bothered me was that
many of the antagonists get flashbacks
to make them more relatable however with
very very poor timing only after they
already have been defeated which sort of
misses the point of making us sympathize
with them
nizuko who is the star of the show in
many ways is extremely lovable yes but
doesn't have a single line of proper
dialogue throughout the series even
though demons can talk and we have other
examples of good demons not eating
humans so why does musical wear that
muzzle all the time
and in general there are a number of
inconsistencies like this throughout the
story at some points i found the pacing
of the plot very poorly chosen where
some fights drag on too long while
important character moments are cut
short or overshadowed by badly timed
comedy demon slayer is not perfect and i
think criticizing certain aspects of the
show is absolutely justified and it's a
shame really because the story could be
so so much more with better character
writing however now with all that being
said why do i still love and strongly
recommend that you watch this anime well
first of all next to character and pace
there is a lot of really decent writing
in this as well i think the premise of
the story is pretty decent as we follow
tanjiro's quest to find a cure for his
demon sister where we follow him growing
up and learning about the world around
him it's a classic shonen arc but very
well executed i think
there is a great balance and great
variety of characters with a very
refreshing take on the female roles not
following the big boob damsel in
distress pattern but actually
introducing a very unique and impressive
cast of male and female characters alike
and on top of that the anime also
doesn't shy away from graphic imagery
and a darker sub tone the two things
that also made you tsukaisen stand out
so much to me
[Music]
is clear from the start and we can fully
understand why he does what he does
this allows us to explore the world of
this anime with him which is the first
thing about kimitsu noyaba where i
personally think it fully outshines many
of its competitors the setting and story
world of this anime are
absolutely fantastic i am a huge fan of
world building and idol period japan was
the perfect choice for this in my
opinion this way we get the best of both
worlds rural met evil looking japan as
well as bright vivid cities times are
changing and we see tradition and katana
meeting electricity and progress we see
the demons funnily enough integrating
into this new world way better than the
demon slayer organization and all the
challenges that come with a changing
country
[Music]
but for me most importantly we get this
beautiful aesthetic of edo period japan
that offers the most romanticized image
that all of us have of japan and that so
many of us love the landscapes are
beautiful the towns and cities are
stunning with detail and despite the
constant threat of the demons there is a
certain sense of peace and stability to
this world do you know that warm feeling
you associate with wonderfully drawn
anime landscapes well demon slayer is
that for every single episode it's a
fantastic if admittedly romanticized
glimpse into a version of japan that you
just don't see all too often in anime
that japanese people are incredibly
proud of which partly i think explains
the crazy success it had domestically
however this already gets me to the core
of this video for me this world only
truly comes to life like this in the
anime the main reason this story became
such a hit and was able to distinguish
itself from its competition was in large
parts thanks to studio ufo table
youthable i have no idea how to
pronounce this actually the studio who
brought this world to life i really
can't praise them enough because that's
how big their contribution has been you
can pause the anime at almost any point
and it looks like a [ __ ] wallpaper
the world feels vibrant and alive the
character designs are colorful and
unique and combined with fantastic voice
acting as well as detail-rich facial
expressions that together make up for a
lot of the characterization missing in
the manga
the production team managed to find a
near flawless balance between 2d and 3d
seamlessly blending the two to allow for
new and exciting camera moments and
action sequences as well as stunning
ambient lighting perfecting what many
other anime struggle with in my opinion
visually demon slayer easily outperforms
most competition of the last few years
it's truly a visual masterpiece the
score created by yuki kachira and
goshina is pretty much perfect with a
rich variety of tracks that by
themselves lift the plot and storyline
to a higher level
[Music]
the openings by the artist lisa are so
popular here in japan that you basically
hear them every day somewhere playing on
some radio station all of that
accentuated by great sound design that
complements the score perfectly
interestingly enough demon slayer not
only won anime of the year at the
crunchyroll awards we can talk about how
legit those are but they also won best
fight scene and i think that this is the
real reason this anime is as successful
as it is the outstanding work of the
visual and sound department came to full
fruition with the many action and
fighting scenes that this anime has
every time that tanjiro swings to
unleash his water breathing it is
followed by a visual firework of these
beautiful lush blue ink-like waves
juxtaposed against a photorealistic
background this is just breathtaking
every single time i see it and even slow
motion which is often used a bit
awkwardly in japanese media is perfect i
mean just just look at this scene
this is some real eye candy right there
while the writing in the manga is far
from impeccable and in some parts is a
little disappointing the concept of the
story overall is solids and taken to the
screen with breathtaking work from the
production team kimitsunuyba in my
opinion is a must-see though you can't
skip the scenes with zainsou in my
opinion it is so incredibly bingeable
and now that season 2 is out with a
pleasure district arc i can't wait to
dive back into this edo period wonder
world and hanson demons if you made it
until here that's the universe telling
you to subscribe welcome on board
no but seriously thanks for subscribing